hey everybody happy Monday I'm Eric
that's Jake as the names would imply we
get to check out a game a little bit
early reviews have actually gone out for
this game but it's a horizon zero dawn
the frozen wilds DLC Peter Brown our
reviews as he manager reviews I can't I
just can't get his title right but he
manages our interviews and he gave this
game this DLC rather an 8 out of 10
I'm gonna go straight into the game here
Jake's gonna tell you a little bit more
about it because he's got his hands on
it I I'm here to just read your
questions on YouTube twitch Facebook and
maybe even Twitter today thank you guys
all for tuning in and thank you gals as
well but yeah Jake how you how you fare
and you're about like one or two hours
in give or take yeah it's him about two
hours took me a little bit longer is
having some trouble with a couple of
enemies early on cuz this game is it's
not hard to come back to in a sense like
I mean it's easy but there's a lot of
different you know weapons you need to
remember and like what certain monsters
or what certain machines are weak to
things of that nature yeah just kind of
familiarizing yourself with exactly the
actual like I'm like like not the
mechanics but the like in-depth
mechanics of the game is like your
counters and whatnot as you mentioned or
what does more damage so what are we
looking at right now like what are we
looking to do okay so I just completed a
story quest I won't go into details just
know guys some people want to leave it
but however the quest opened up and it
wants me to actually I think they all
are on side yeah so it gave me four side
quests that I need to come to nice ok so
we're just kind of gonna do these cool
and he said to kind of access this well
so the game will be available I would
presumably think 9 p.m. Pacific tonight
which is 12 a.m. Eastern
I believe it's 1999 but you also said
you need to be a little 30 I think
it's 32 32 but yeah it's not you can't
just get the game and jump into this
gotcha
it's like north of kind of the stuff you
yeah actually I do
nice so we're gonna get the tall neck as
well so hopefully this all clear up and
you'll be able to see more of it yeah I
don't know which one is the tall neck go
find out okay hello look out
well medicine pouch is full that doesn't
happen very often yeah so that's the one
thing that I think kind of deterred me a
little bit in playing the game even
though it's a very small kind of gripe
for me is that you have to you know farm
all your herbs for your you know your
healing and whatnot but I'm sure it's
not too hard to find the herbs I saw you
already picks them up and like you said
in this case you're kind of filled your
pouch already but I'm so used to like
Dark Souls and games like that where
you're going from like to your bonfire
and things like that and you're like
okay cool I got all my health back you
know or all my potions back so yeah I
wish there cuz if you don't have a lot
of like spare health it's gonna be tough
it can't be tough if you don't know what
you're doing so it can be kind of a pain
like you're in the middle of a fight and
it's like alright the only way I'm gonna
do is if I go back and just hunt for
roots oh yeah here we go here we come
some combat here we're playing a ps4
just a normal ps4 a light these guys on
fire fight cold Jake so this is quite
good fit up
oh right in the head
and then like you can craft your weapons
on the fly as well it's pretty cool or
your I mean still like one of the kind
of like the prettiest in games this year
it is this is even a pro and PlayStation
exclusive
the melee combat it's not as uh it's
mainly about the bow and arrow obviously
but you do end up getting these melee
weapons and and what I've seen the melee
stuff is kind of just okay it's mainly
focused more around the bow and arrow so
if you like bow and arrows you know
obviously you've priority playing this
game but what's up feeling good though
yeah and then there's all these fun
combinations you can do you start
tethering things and a lot of different
ways to go about playing it I will
dislike your video okay thanks good my
gaming I'll still take that as engaging
got him you can't trick us here well at
least not all the time so blue gleam
which I just found here is kind of a new
currency here it's very rare to come by
but it's how you get the new armor sets
and weapon okay weapons I think I have
enough to get something maybe not
anything too good so we can okay well we
can take a look at that fine second have
you seen a lot of new enemy types so I
believe there are three new enemy types
I've seen two of them so far ones a
grizzly bear thing which is pretty rad
Philip Elliott asking so is this big
enough as a deal see is there much of a
difference to bring me back in other
than it's snowy well as Jake just
mentioned there's a couple new bosses
you know obviously new armor and weapons
it's probably still kind of more of
Wednesday more of the same but there's
got to be a lot of elements that are
similar right there's gonna be some new
things as well what you can do to
Phillip Phillip Elliot or Phil Elliot
rather is you can check out Peters
review where he kind of talks more about
it let me give you the pros and cons
from that how is it though
whoo right in the foot oh oh there's
another one that's a bigger one too okay
he didn't see you where she as mentioned
Peter gave it an 8 out of 10 sorry Peter
I'm only reading the good and the bad
the good a vast and beautiful new a
stretch of land to explore new gear that
emphasizes the strategic use of elements
across the map a big selection of new
skills that make item management and
exploration easier I remember how much
the item management stuff lauded Peter
so that's been enhanced that's awesome
and impressive new enemies to fight the
bad is it tells an underwhelming story
so if you're looking for more story it
probably doesn't do oh boy we've got a
buy one get one free here a bad kind
because there's there's two two big
baddies here but we'll see if Jake
manages to do this you know early on in
the stream starting off with an intense
fight here and snow loved seeing the
snow just dropping as you're fighting
here I'm not even looking at the animal
I'm looking at the snow
whoo get dodge damn they're not messing
around looking like in this game if
you're fighting two machines you don't
see other once you start rolling because
it is it's gonna come yeah this is a
nice little loop you got going on him
though yeah get rid of that
all right got that Terrier honor
glad Jake is playing and I'm not this is
looks very intense especially with two
two at one as mentioned earlier
oh yeah that was great like spread arrow
tears oh that's just a terror you're
good you still have quite a good thing
you had full health oh yeah it's fine
totally fine yeah as mentioned guys if
you guys have questions feel free to
shoot those in the chat I will relay
those to Jake it and see if you can
answer them if not we'll try our best
obviously
one down nice all right
Oh out of ammo is kind of craft on the
fly
strike the only I wonder you're like I
mean I know I don't know how much breath
of the wild actually impacted this game
but I hope enough people played it
because this was like a week before I
think breath of the wild and yeah I
think yeah I think we had the benefit
cuz we got it a little bit early so it
didn't really two switches so this got
passed to me and I got to play it's very
good overshadowed I remember it was
crazy time for Peter to because he had
to review this game and then he switched
to breath of the wild and I mean but I
mean like if anything it was it was
obviously still fortunate because like
you know both games are very good I
think he gave 0.9 recall correctly and
then obviously he gave but the wild of
ten but two solid games to kind of play
in that that week
oh I'm so sorry you know what that's
totally my fault I was like dude chats
not actually going and I'm like there's
all these people in here dude on the
left opinion sucks as enteric well my
time on the left yeah technically yeah
I always forget cuz it's opposite of
where we're actually see yeah so stop
crying about picking up herbs you can
crash potions yeah I know but still hey
I gotta go out and pick herbs I guess I
played wow and I picked the herbs all
the time so I guess I should actually
not complain about that I guess that's
fair I guess that's fair marty-mar I'll
take that criticism that's fair
blue gleam is something you collect
right Jake yes it is it's it's basically
just a currency but it's much harder to
find in merchants last for like ten or
fifteen as opposed to asking for like a
couple thousand four so kind of is it
can you get them on random dropped I
think so
okay well we'll see I think you get a
morena drop you can also just find them
in the environment they're almost like
herbs
no worries bill see Christ they're
soaked you see Crist
will try to find some of these new
monsters to fight
Vitara asking should I buy horizon zero
dawn the complete edition now in
December for the full experience I'm
guessing now or in December I mean it's
up to you how you want to play the game
right like if you want to have the whole
thing any probably just want to wait but
if you want to play the game and then
play this expansion just get it now I
guess the snow looks as good as Jake
says John the nerd a lot of people
asking if the DLC it's worth buying Jake
meet Jake's Mike needs to be louder I
guess you just have to put it closer to
your mouth to talk louder yeah you talk
louder that's Jake you played the game
obviously more than I have do you feel
like I mean obviously you only play two
hours so take that information based off
of that information yes but do you feel
like you would buy this or you think
it's worth buying I would buy this yeah
20 bucks it seems to have a lot to it
plus I really like this game and I think
the combat is fantastic and just an
excuse to go back and play that combat
or to you know do that combat again
especially fighting these new machines
there's a lot of fun but I mean if you
played it's not like necessary to the
story so if you played it and you know
like all right I got my fill then may
not be worth it for you yeah it's just
do you want more horizon zero dawn right
and part of it too the cool thing is I
think it's like I think it's like
roughly like 15 hours I think is the DLC
like laying this I'm sure it could be a
little bit faster depending on you know
if you do all the side stuff or not do
all the side stuffs oh man which trial
should i do first control you go while
trailer chieftains for I don't know you
pick a trial or we can let the chat
decide with some delay or not
machines really yeah that's fine there
are quests tigers lion sidequest as well
as like main quests I can get my butt
kicked that's fine it is $19.99 for this
dlc stand normal if that's what you're
asking
some people are gonna wait for the
complete edition that's not a bad idea
if you haven't played it because one
thing Peter said in his review is that
like you almost wish to see was able to
play this before finishing the main game
well there you go from the story stuff
that you have experience does if kind of
follow the main part or is it just kind
of a little side story on its own it's
kind of a little Side Story on his own
it feeds into the main quests like in
terms of just backstory but it's not
like headshot I shot I shot
yeah breadth of the wilds DLC is $20 as
well yeah that's come December right
early December anything uh teager's line
I think God of War is or like they say
early 2018 whatever that means
he won oh all right so you gotta clear
this is way too of your trial don't have
miss with tear arrows they are not whoo
that was nice
can you go back to the main area on this
again yes right it's it's it's not like
I know a lot of games are my admin there
is it's like all right go through this
loading screen it is like it fits in
you soup
technically Peter's in charge of all
review so any of the freelance reviews
would be kind of at least partially
worked with through Peter and all right
click somewhere oh there's a more
oh yeah can you send that melee combat
and this is still just way too crazy
probably got to be like a bigger wine at
some point yeah
oh maybe not oh there's there's one way
yeah cool it's like kind of like neo you
know like there's certain areas where
you have like three different like horde
Modi waves and it gets like you know
obviously harder from each one and
usually the third one was like a boss
boss I wonder if this is something you
can return doing it gets harder because
it seems like a common trend with DLCs
out of wave based mode yeah also really
you guys know if you guys were
interested in neo neo complete edition
comes out I think tomorrow too so don't
finally be on PC actually yeah I forgot
that didn't originally launched on PC
yeah no just a ps4 exclusive still is in
terms of console because yeah it's just
PC but it's good that the PC crowd will
get that game too because you know not
everyone has a voice issue looking
forward to that too I didn't finish all
the deals to use I just played enough of
each one I'm a bad boy he was a pretty
meaty game to score he was a lot longer
than I thought it was thank you wow it
took I think it depends too because
there's a lot of side stories or side
missions in that game you're definitely
looking at that like 40 plus hours
though if you get a lot of stuff
do you know how many more trophies there
are in this this because of the DLC I do
not look okay we can take a look later
guys you guys are curious like
restrictions there weren't really any
okay cool you looked at the embargo
better than I did I just knew I was like
can we stream this today and Peter was
like yeah totally it's like alright then
we're totally doing that yeah I mean I
didn't say any specifics so I'm just
kind of like avoiding got you a lot of
stories stuff that seems very mean you
do have to do this in the story but you
know I don't think anything here is like
they got to you right Trident warrior
asking well we need to complete the
final quest the looming shadow in order
to play the frozen wiles or can we play
it straight off the bat I don't think
you need to complete the final quest but
there is a quest that you do need a
complete before you can access and then
as well as being the level requirement
thing right yeah so I think as Jake
mentioned earlier it's either 30 or 32
or somewhere in there for the level
requirement and I guess you'll know
which question you have to do they kind
of get in there was that just in the
main area the quest offender sorry
hello there's the big boy
hello that's yeah some environmental
damage so yeah there seems that as Jake
mentioned there's a course that you need
to do to get up this way and then like
also just be 3032 around that level and
you two can play this wow it's a nice
one that's really recommend ter way yeah
it's dimly his guns but doesn't do a lot
of damage to them yeah but that makes
him easier right do that yeah stop by
Chi
that makes us kind of get rid of the
annoying guys who's a dog okay it's okay
you got that to them sweet iframes baby
okay did you use the those trap arrows
that much or I do I haven't used them
because they've kind of been any more
open areas get one going here though I
know that's what guys gonna run right
into it I like that
Wow the ice is also breaking now he's in
the water he's done too far away yeah
all right
three damn it show me that hot body of
yours that underbelly
I'm not sure the actual quest name
you'll Bonnie I don't know if Jake do
you remember the quest that you did to
kind of get up here oh we can look oh
you mean to get to this edge you get to
this area look I don't remember
Yahtzee
nice first try no problem we'll try to
get you that information if we can't
find it here I'm sure it sounds like a
pretty good article too like how to how
to unlock or how to get to the frozen
wilds I can probably look now actually
all right let's see the quest show
completed oh yeah they did it showed its
check mark stuff yeah so he still has
the looming shadow for the person asking
it appears into the frozen wild there
you go can't go back to that real quick
it's so you have to talk or wait are we
just okay it tells you to go yeah there
you go it's basically up north like if
you go up north you'll find someone who
will tell you about it and trigger it
and and then you can head that way I
think there's someone in I forget what
the main town in this game is called
meridian meridian there's someone in
Meridian who I think also mentions it
that you can Alexandria yeah different
game it's weird
after playing so much Assassin's Creed
going back to this is like wow guerrilla
games did everything you do soft tries
to do but better heard it here first
from Jake approach up in the future
ravages don't like fire it's Changsha
okay yeah see like I can do it three
times
I would don't think I have to try
another one have we seen a new bad guy
yet like new no canticle well we'll
leave this for now we'll do we're gonna
go we're gonna find the tall neck and
then from the tall neck we can figure
out where sweet holy crap they're far is
that the talkback right there that one
that you just oh yeah it's right here
you fast travel
yeah a long way oh but new kudos baby
strong location invalid fast no all
right I can call them out though where's
my cab low sorry so stuck in it
it's a street mode to Bob Jones question
a case wat you think they'll make a
sequel to this game and if they do have
loot boxes I don't know about a sequel
well I don't know Peter said this kind
of sets up okay well there you go
so I I imagine I think they will I hope
they do yeah I don't see why they would
need to add loot boxes to this game but
you've never known the climate of loot
boxes that is 20 the year of 2000 got a
couple treasure box open that's fine
that's not a not the same thing Jake
don't trick the people on stream
kristaps rensis the it should release at
9 p.m. Pacific which is in roughly nine
and a half hours is my guess which is
12:00 a.m. Eastern curious 1999 or I
believe someone said you could buy I
think the complete edition which
you
go ahead I feel so weird killing like
goats and things like that in this game
and like wild animals
they just seem confused we gotta eat
something so he can't eat robot parts
I know so one of the things they added
is that you can gather things while on
horseback which is really nice so
release is in December the complete
edition for $49.99 December 5th in the
US December 6th in Europe which is a
month after frozen wallets and let's see
the complete edition as mentioned $50
the same as the price that the base game
currently sells for frozen wild sells
for 20 up as mentioned but PS Plus
subscribers could pre-order the
expansion or the DLC for 15 the digital
deluxe edition goes for 60 on PSN and
includes the following art of horizon
zero dawn digital art book exclusive ps4
theme largest storm ranger outfit and
mighty bow but new Trailblazer outfit
and Cohen bow but new traveler pack cars
or trader pack Nora keep it back so if
anything it sounds more like you know
how can we add more stuff to the
editions and not so much that we've lost
but I ran over a bunny you did just got
trampled
oh well [ __ ] happens is the frozen while
it's gonna be in the New Game+ or not
yes all right well I wasn't talking
about us paying for any of those boxes
that is definitely not that it was just
in the game Jake was just commenting on
the fact that he has crates that he
could open but they are not paid for it
see I told ya so I told you that would
compute fire ups aren't confused the
screen ooh
knocked right off this looks sketchy
like four little ones on you
Kiba alaric asking a cane spot now is
this a whole new map or is it just added
to the original map and also is there a
new level cab so the map is this North
right and it's a section of the main
yeah pull it up I can pull it up yeah so
this I don't remember this section here
but all this is new okay so it's a new
section of the main map I guess if that
answers your question
is there a new level cap uh I believe so
I think Peters said they increased it to
60 but I don't know what it was before
I'm guessing like 50 if you finish the
game chances are you'll be over level
this will still have some challenge yeah
I mean like that one part that trial
you're just in which was the what first
of three still kind of was pretty
difficult did you fight a bear yet I did
I actually right before this I'm hoping
I can all right before this Jake
it was love a story missions I don't
want to I just okay sorry xariah I just
wanted to clear that up in case anyone
thought that you know but we'll see we
can fight another bear I think once I
activate this tall neck I can see where
they are and we can I'm sweet they're
tough
we need some new armor that we're gonna
crack later or something
yeah here if I don't hit you in a weak
point come on right over got him
Jesse James can I carry on from where I
left the original game using the shield
Weaver armor I think so
I'll keep Alaric thinks that that
section looks a little small I think
well as mentioned I don't know so much
in terms of the like area but like it's
supposed to be roughly about 15 hours of
gameplay I'm guessing that's with a lot
of side missions and things like that so
it's still pretty substantial but uh I
sure Jake hasn't even traversed all of
it yet either so I have her but I've
done I've done one I've done a couple
mission he says like a lot of fogs so
you know but yeah it seems like some of
that gameplay will come from doing those
trials and whatnot so
it's so good have you got to be on the
back like that the disk because it says
you're like 11 - a meters but I don't
know if that's actually true
hey life does not seem safe can you go
on that thing you jump onto that without
[ __ ] there you go no that not it I mean
this is a tall neck it's like wow
interesting
well okay normally look at you here yeah
so that no no so like if you look at
your compass like there that you see
that you're tall neck is right I mean
this is yeah I know I'm just basing it
off the compass and I thought you had to
like align yourself on it
DLC only unloved home
all night yeah replace Rhys - you got to
replace the components to get it to run
again critical components are removed
he's that high don't fall off all right
maybe I just did follow these down
good to do something with it though no
just straight shooting it I know that
clearly you know work do any of the
surrounding enemies or anything like
that drop that stuff for you I mean I I
feel like I should have that stuff I've
got so much junk okay
that's the weaver one well you're doing
is equip is the thing you're actually at
that for the work plus yeah this is part
of it okay cool so you have to fix the
tall necks yes we got to figure out how
to fix it
whole mix yeah you do have to have the
full game to play this I think in maybe
the surrounding animals or you know
those one two three spots on the map do
those are those separate quests fine or
do you think they actually oh yeah so
you didn't have to kill it now you got a
stand steady you got a usually kill
stuff man that's how it goes Eevee we
have shown the new map a couple times
now so if you just want to scrub back in
DVR on YouTube you'll see it so you
gotta find I gotta find the parts which
don't seem too far okay yep they're like
no damage we're fine
yeah no damage oh there is that one on
one right over here
sweet where's our snowboard you know is
that shield
that's unfortunate any other wolf if you
just sold this game yeah maybe go
complete edition in December then your
best bet at this point yeah I mean if
you're safe just go ahead and setup them
traps hopefully I'll get some herbs Oh
what was that
and two guys the trap yeah that's what
I'm talking about
do another one come on come on get snuck
up on look at that rain oh this game has
not come out for pc yet does ps4 only
right now the what about they never come
to PC one of the games that did come to
PC those PS war only earlier this year
was neo that or not yet I guess that's
tomorrow
but neo complete edition PC will be out
tomorrow and I think complete edition
gives you all the DLC C which is a
pretty good deal that's pretty good
though coz it's not one piece nice
alright it's probably gotta go get some
bigger B's unloved home he says I'm
gonna have to try this yeah yeah I can't
wait to play neo on love Tommy on PC I
wanted to check that out today but we're
doing we chose to do this instead or
maybe if there's enough interest maybe
we just do it later I don't know I know
all I know is that that starting area is
gonna be real easy this time around I
mean once I get my muscle memory for key
pulses and stuff back in that but I feel
like I feel like I'm gonna be fine just
fine for that game to start just two
guys now again we are playing horizon
zero dawn the frozen wild DLC it comes
out in roughly nine hours
come at me come at me Oh God
it is 1999 I think I did read earlier if
you have PS plus you could potentially
preorder it for a little less but
someone would have to try jeez
you just gotta have a weakness that you
have exploiting I mean I think that
really is that how that works he's a
fire element to type but then we can all
see it so well because he's got those
little like gas tanks ah gotcha okay so
like it doesn't do much damage but if I
also we're trying to find a bear to kill
I see it work hey you after work
Oh getting a little hairy you're out of
line
get rid of this little guy okay
I didn't hit the gas thing but yeah you
just didn't have the right all right Oh
a little damage a little fall dommage
we're we're good you got like 50% hauled
I believe he's got like half life it's a
pretty even fight break the tanks with
fire yeah he just tried trust me he
tried
oh he's gonna try again cuz that's how
badass Jake is whoo Jake what do you see
well potion yeah oh that didn't do that
much damage or that spectacle of all the
explosion it did not that much yeah
right in the fifth spray in the face ran
the kisser
there you go house nice it's close
put some traps down Jesus I did a man
everyone some traps I want to say
everyone plays a little differently I
think that's the beauty of games like
these with different life skills and
whatnot hopefully with this game there's
so many different weapons that all serve
multiple purposes hopefully it's just
you below I'm not sure oh yes I'll just
ask the stream house everyone stream
looking is there any stutters or
anything like that or you guys pretty
good because I did have to switch
machines recently and there has been
some up and downs with this machine
trying to fix our normal rig yeah
all right yeah get some herbs
shrim looks good so Scoob thank you I
blame Comcast today looks good here
after rebooting my modem router suite
all right yeah I can never tell if it's
like on our end or if it's like like on
the user and because sometimes it does
happen a lot of stuttering says
Appleyard one that's not so great
you see if I can other person says
stream is smooth dang it Internet why
are you always divisive yeah yes there's
a DLC her oak doughnuts it comes on in
about nine hours oh that looks cool
I'm liking this scene
oh this is awkward day went for that
Oh death from above didn't assassinate
thing Oh kind of crap why are we hanging
on what are we doing because you like
mantling it is not available for
purchase yet Daniel prl but it will be
in about nine hours I mean you can
technically pre-purchase it but in terms
of actually playing right now not so
much for y'all we have a early got
access to the game I'm mildly nervous
for Jake right now he is in a sticky
situation
luckily he has crafted potions not a
whole lot though you're good it's gonna
be fine
hey shot down all right
two more no problem aim says Bob Jones
not like this shake death number one
gang saw was your game of the year
aspirin rocks 26 you'll find out soon
enough
we're gonna start having those fun
deliberations but it's not over yet for
now we we still got some games to be
playing you know lower some of this
stuff we are on a casual ps4 I like that
I like that Alex where you go I'm call
it the casual ps4 we're not on a pro
right now
Peter review does on a pro though that
is correct you put it all on a pro I
don't have a pro so we're not getting
pro uh you'll Bonnie Reyes Martinez
frozen wild should be in new game+ and
also the original I think you're just
playing an original right yeah so there
you go rip says Nathan Shepard that was
a rip if there was ever a rip but yeah
haven't your ps4 electricity works
wonder on those guys says and enteric
after he said fail but thank you for the
tip
you still have the other two parts
though right you just gotta get this son
yeah just one laughs I don't even think
that was to get the part
actually I don't know we'll see at the
last one oh yeah yeah I have one left
but I don't know if that was yeah I
think you're right I think that was the
last one going back up I wonder if I
have any electricity Oh actually yeah
everyone now asking is this on a pro or
a PlayStation 4 we're on a casual ps4 or
amateur ps4 is there a new skill tree
wants to see the new skill tree there
you go is it this far right traveler
traveler I don't like a whole lot yet
yeah it like it almost seems more like
quality of life stuff like this is super
helpful like gather resources oh that's
pretty good well mount it like that's
that's pretty nice are there new weapons
there are new weapons welcome after one
in a little bit you know hopefully we'll
maybe I know you definitely had enough
for armor I didn't ask you about weapons
so should put you on the spot for that
one oh hello
like that little slide animation
pistol' Peter save you would have had
probably like a lot of goodies I know so
many goodies Joe a Sodor welcome to the
stream we it is not live for everyone
yet but it will be tonight glad you
could tune in and check it out with me
and Jake we're trying to reactivate a
long neck hair but to do that we gotta
get some some parts but before we can
get those parts I think I'm gonna need
some help stuff all right we're gonna
get some herbs some dankel herbs and
yeah if you guys have questions I will
try to send those to Jake but Jake has
only played about two hours so far so
anything deeper than that might be
asking for a bit just to give you guys a
heads up we were trying to also locate a
bear that would be awesome find a bear
who Jake has said is pretty tough like I
took out one like I didn't get hurt much
taking out one it took a while but
knowing this scheme they'll they'll
probably throw two at you at some point
and that is probably very difficult all
right I'm at least gonna try to fill up
one more pouch yeah fill that pouch also
if you guys haven't already hit that
subscribe button and that like button in
that follow button it will help notify
you guys when we do actually go live
with cool games like the frozen while
it's a little early so yeah do that we
also make a lot of cool features Joey
just put up a really cool feature about
Cup head with the cup head devs and this
is the first of a couple but this first
one is about how if you guys have seen
them the Frog bosses are influenced
quite a bit by Street Fighter and
there's also some other fighting game
references in there as well so if you
guys are fans of Cup head and also
fighting games I suggest you check that
out did you finish up it I have not yet
very close are you very close then
October 27th happen and I had the
stop yeah and that's the thing I haven't
played much since the Dragons I gave
them a go and I got them to like like
literally like a sliver of that finish
line and then I couldn't replicate it
again and I was just so I was tilted I
just yeah 100% on till I was like man I
got it like what the hell and I died for
a stupid reason to I think there you go
probably pretty tough thanks how is to
have viewers come in and play while we
stream but sniperscope
this is oh yeah
sorry I just read the above yeah someone
said they pre-recorded the DLC and then
someone made fun that this was
pre-recorded and I was like nope
actually I get it now he meant pre-order
yeah long story short he snowboard down
a hill or Sheol or on a shield no we
just slide down this booth you do that
yeah no actual snowboarding home god I
think so I think the problem with
scavenging is that it it's not there's
not as much health ones as I'd like it's
a lot of like shock wax and like it's
especially right now and I'm just trying
to yeah when you need to make sure you
got an ample supply I don't know if I'll
enough but I'll give it a shot you might
be okay maybe you'll find someone the
way
I think maybe it'll help if I gets down
there as well
that is pretty tight little area yeah
they got you there they got their home
turf you know the little nest well also
try to find some new enemies there's
like three I think is what Jake said
yeah I mean in the thing it shows for
the fourth one is kind of like a tower
that when it's up it consistently kills
enemies you can get a better start here
than what we got on a pin wall okay
stay down
oh so close all right way better start I
think you got one like really low and
then okay there's a really weak one and
the third one has like a full life I
think cuz I was the one who didn't
forget to pin down but I think it's one
on one
no problem you got this
Jacob record that what we should call
you from now on
sure Jacob record their worst things
call me did he fall
Appleyard one trying to figure out what
game to play been getting a bit bored
from games lately really and there's so
many good games to play I feel like
especially right now yeah like Super
Mario yeah it happens to me every now
and then it's like well I'm just saying
like I think there's like it feels like
there's a good amount of diversity oh I
don't know trying to think of all the
games that are out that you could play
depending on if you have played them or
not you know like yeah Wolfenstein you
know the new Colossus just came out
assuming you played Wolfenstein
Assassin's Creed origins just came out
yeah Mario Odyssey you have you know
this horizon zero dawn the frozen wilds
DLC neo complete edition coming out
tomorrow there's a bunch of switch stuff
coming out soon like dooms gonna come
out on switch Skyrim guy was gonna be
out on switch la noir and then Call of
Duty obviously just came out if you're
into the cod series battlefront twos
about to come out
there's more and I just can't even think
about it there's there's two like for me
there's like too many games I feel like
I can't even get around to playing all
of them but I do I do understand though
like I must kind of like a specific type
of gamer with certain games so like I
don't play them all either so like if
they don't build it
gotta have loot and the itch yeah I
gotta have Lee if he doesn't feel the
itch that you want and like I can
understand that
you know if the type of game you you
enjoy playing hasn't really been coming
out then that that's definitely tough
but it was I'm like last year for me
like last year was really good for
shooters and like multiplayer games like
overwatch and I I liked overwatch but
these aren't these aren't the games I
typically enjoy so last year kind of
felt dry like a dry spell for me but I
know a lot of people thought last year
is great cuz like titanfall and yeah
overwatch what else yeah toast man x aka
crisper news editor at GameSpot saying
he's overwhelmed with games and
sniperscope saying destiny two came in
and stopped playing when I reached 305 Y
but I understand don't worry you got a
expansion coming up in December in the
month
need for speed yes also coming out this
week I think that's hen it's been a
while yeah we're gonna try to stream you
for speed k back some time this week but
I also want to stream Doom 1 switch cuz
I just think and if I can find any
excuse to play doom
we're gonna do do you want to age that's
for sure if I have to do if we had to do
to live streams then we just got to do
to live streams that day why what
happened I wasn't quick enough
so what happened this is where I have to
jump on the tall neck oh so now I could
do it over there maybe you better figure
this out you can't just like climb on
him no I have to jump on it oh there's
enemies there - no that's what their
another spot there usually is face sauce
Oh yep mm-hmm
new a little skill there pick up them
the herbs oh here you go here you go
this is this has got to be the wine
this should be a good spot Jake get you
out of my face and into his face all
right where is it all right you got a
little bit of time here
Richard Costas a Remo succeeds greater
than Cod Rainbow six siege is about to
get an update to I forget the date but
that that got announced cowboy Johnny 73
saying he's got a 1 X waiting for him
tomorrow I think you got you're getting
the 1 X 2 right I'm as well yeah I still
like part of me part of the problem for
me is like there still isn't a good
enough reason for me personally to get 1
X or an Xbox one just plays there's no
games out there that I like yeah so I
the biggest reason I'm getting one is
because I all my friends back home have
one they play on xbox now I have an Xbox
in works I got launched one I had to get
rid of it because it was too damn loud
but I'm finally getting ok instead of on
PC you know I'll still probably mostly
play on PC but like I said that's what
all my friends play on so we'll probably
be playing a lot of that running rocks
26 how do you what's the rest of the
question
this is still 15 only for today says
Robo death X I think yeah I think the
pre-order if you're on PS plus if you
pre-orders 15 today instead of 20 so
you're thinking about it it's probably
better deal to do it today otherwise TX
man 210 it's normally $19.99 or you can
wait for the complete edition as well I
wanna say this is the guy on the lefts
opinions are getting better thanks to
enteric slowly but surely I will climb
the opinions meter as long as they're
pretty neutral but I like to I'd like to
thank you for telling me that I've
leveled up a little bit all right let's
find can you find them now that you've
gotten the can you find the new stuff to
fight I think this is one but I'm not
entirely sure well what the only way to
find out Jake is if we go there's this
is the only new one I have logged I
forgot to log oh wait this is it right
here though but alright let's go back to
the map then alright so our two
objectives that we'll try to hit in the
next half an hour because that's roughly
how much longer your stream is we need
to find a bear and we need to find a new
enemy type that is your job Jake
alright maybe one of these quests will
even to it literally his job depends on
this said 1990 said are left are game
spots left I think when he said when
enteric says left he means me because
that's what you guys should be seeing is
that I'm on the left because of the
pictured picture but technically in this
studio I'm on the right all right we're
gonna go on another quest is that what
are you doing and in the hopes that you
run into something that we want to see
that's what I'm hoping all right sounds
good no this is the wrong question
though
all right so you're doing that one
already but the first part of that was
to do the atomic stuff so correct yeah
go to songs edge
well okay so I can go back here at least
and because it's close by I can see if I
can get a new weapon okay let's do that
that's a nice little side objective for
us - where's my mallets you said three
new machines and then kind of like a
fourth which is like a tower right it
heals them when they're near that seems
really annoying to deal with it can be
especially if they noticed you if you're
doing stealth like it's not that bad you
just got to get there and yeah
run rocks 26 asking gamespot how do you
think the future of graphics will look
with all the colors or will it look
ultra realistic I don't know I mean
things look better and better as we go
on obviously but I think you also have
to have the hardware for that to look
well like good and even for myself like
I don't even have a 4k TV right now just
because I haven't felt the need for it I
guess I know that we're slowly
gravitating towards a world of 4k but
I'm just not there yet I guess I mean
there are certain games like horizon for
example this is a good example where the
4k actually like it's like yep okay that
is a pretty good reason to have 4k but
you know and there's a there's also
other good examples as well but I don't
feel like there's that many for me
personally so own one yet so in because
of that I haven't bought a ps4 pro or
xbox honex
either yet so you have you must have a
4k TV I don't got a 1x I'm getting one
I'm waiting for Black Friday
that's smart yeah that's actually a good
shout too because that's like I don't
know 20 days from now a little less it's
close yeah and like they aren't
ridiculously expensive anymore - mm-hmm
I mean if you get a small one there like
a 40 like a less than 50 inch one yeah
yeah and the other thing too is like I
think it depends on the game I think
certain games will look more and more
realistic like the short human stuff
looks pretty crazy so does the last of
us but I don't know if that was just a
cinematic I think it might have just
missed animatic so oh yeah don't forget
about the trophies yeah we'll check that
out in a bit I don't know if that one is
like one of those where we're not
supposed to spoil I feel like trophies
might be something we probably shouldn't
show yeah I was kind of worried about
that and because the game's not out yet
so I don't think I don't know if we can
spoil the trophies but you can only make
a green armor that seems good
so I don't have enough blue gleam all
right we gotta get some glue clean then
uh ego dreamer its it's roughly supposed
to be 15 hours but I'm sure it could be
faster if you just don't do every side
like if you're not a completionist but
it'll probably be like 12 to 15 is my
guess but most I think it's roughly 15
goop says go big or go home 75 inch or
bus dude that's not the wrong motto but
it depends on your room structure yeah
it didn't put in 75 inch if you're like
3 2 to 3 feet away from it it doesn't
work that way
marco piazza I heard the DLC was
overhyped as a shoe I don't think so I
think a lot of people are enjoying this
I think though if you're looking for
more story you're not gonna really get
too much in that sense but if you're
looking for more horizon zero dawn you
know some new skills some new weapons
and your armor a couple new enemies this
is definitely it
you know I got a new bow oh it's it is
it better than what you have now all
right so you're gonna use it then yeah
actually
alright alright so we gotta get some
more blue gleam we also need to oh you
told me it was a bow not like a gun bow
yeah that's not a new weapon alright
it's a new type of weapon oh it is any
type of this is sweet alright got a new
weapon alright unfortunately but not one
of the cool rarer ones there cuz I'm a
blue balloon that's fine we can get some
more maybe I did you need a lot no I
needed six but you know I found eight in
two hours three hours now okay affair
alright are there any new mods that was
Larry kid asked I think so I've been
getting a bunch of mods I haven't messed
with my mods to mod and what about
headdress but he wants you to do
something with that weapon so not this
so this one yeah hold an alright now
what Jake we gotta get a bear and a new
new monsters find one cuz looking at the
map they usually say where they are look
at that what's what's up with that uh
when I have marked no to the right
what's the skull with a double like the
hut is that anything I don't know panic
camp maybe yeah that's not so great then
you got a new quest of course we do new
quests where did you fight the first
bear actually you know what I bet if I
keep doing the hunting grounds
you know the those wave things I said
I'll fight one eventually a bear yeah or
a new monster or new I I think a foe one
or the other alright I might get my butt
kicked butt sure yeah
we'll see we'll see yeah well we'll get
to use any weapon yeah you know so
there's that how many do you know how
many new weapon types are I think this
is the only new weapon type but I
wouldn't quote me on that I think from
when I read Peters review it sounded
like this was the only one but obviously
there you can get them to fire different
elements I'm sure mm-hmm so Oh
Marco I want to say that it ties in a
little bit but as mentioned I don't
think this story is what you should be
hoping too much more in terms of this
you'll see expansion yeah according to
Peter it kind of sets up more but it
doesn't really address any of that it's
like but don't forget you still have
this whole main story you need to finish
because it's not it doesn't the place
after it takes place right before that
the last the end of the game hello
Cluedo its 2016 are you playing a new
game place no this is just normal robo
death wants to see that bear they don't
call you Jacob
record for nothing you got this man that
was Nathan Shepard thank you fingers
crossed is the armor you're using that
Opie armor no no Peter has the ope
well isn't even Opie though I heard it
was like is it the one that heals over
time oh okay then they had seems pretty
pretty good I could have gotten that
that was one I could have gotten there
but it won't but it wasn't rare so we
didn't Oh
time for some trials on slow oh man
going for the second tier oh man all
right here we go
I finished a normal game what's the best
way to do the deal see I mean I guess
your new game flushing and then getting
to that area if you finish the game you
just go for it
oh can you okay you know it's the same
thing well I was lied to cake at least
show me the new weapon oh I can try one
of the other trials ooh get shocked
that seemed pretty anti-climatic me yeah
or not seem like it was it
seems okay I mean I'm sure I guess weak
to electricity it seems pretty good yeah
maybe we got a second Opie Armour in
this DLC all I know is I want to see
what the chat wants to see which is a
fair
type which we're not sure if you'll try
you tell me don't know cuz it looks the
same right I mean we're fighting the
same enemies right now this is the
exactly the same well a raised rifle
pool it stabbed
I just don't want you to use all your
health packs for this parvum I might
just die and do a different one your
instincts said otherwise
not a fan of that new weapon huh yeah
that's what I'm talking about
you gotta go waste it I've got a gun now
yeah it's fine it's fine
although I guess you have to you got to
create the ammo for it though huh yeah
which actually I should add Electric
mods to make it okey then I can't do
that
Oh create that weapon and it's god-like
do you guys know this or you guys just
telling him to try it coming
you guys haven't played the game yet we
don't know if it'll be Opie if he mods
it it's just a hypotheses
so that is a little unfortunate though
if the trial is just the same thing
yeah there's I mean it looked like there
were three tears that's why I was yeah
there's got to be something different
though other than I mean like it doesn't
look any harder enteric saying trials
are the exact same rewards are only
different based upon the time taken to
complete monsters won't change well
there you go
want to can you get out of this thing
after you pick up those herbs I don't
think so maybe I can load save do you
want to do that though we'll have the
tall neck done yeah okay well there's
only one spot left okay well then just
go do it real quick
where did you fight the bear the first
time it was a story mission I know do
you have an old save that we could just
go back to the bear then mm-hmm yes I
know Kevin Lauritzen I think I've
butchered your last name there faction
rally in dusty 2 is back tomorrow first
time for PC we will definitely I will
definitely be sure you mean that
tomorrow so if you guys are into destiny
2 which I know there's gonna be some
haters it's fine coming back tomorrow
and we'll go do that thing ok it's not 3
tears you get bronze silver or gold
which one how long it takes you to
complete thank you sir
and it will end okay oh you just walk
out of the zone into away oh really
yeah I think Jake just feels committed
now
but don't you start the fight the big
guy
oh yeah yeah oh no we came from behind
I'm gonna put up a fight but I'm not
thank you okay feel like you should have
said that earlier and later goes so dirt
it's fun thanks for tuning in this is
early gameplay Hector this is like a
review copy essentially the game is not
out yet but the DLC will be out later
tonight I don't like 9 hours well us now
currently doing a trial we try to find a
bear and also try to find some new
enemies to fight we got the new weapon
pretty cool I think he needs to probably
mod it at some point to make it better
but it's only a blue somebody wants to
hold off you heal what the hell
I knew muscle-memory was just her day oh
yeah all right well hopefully Jake not
gonna not gonna commentate her curse
this will this DLC be available on
floppy disks no I don't think that
technology exists anymore maybe a zip
disco or an MD stuck on a rope
Oh still alive oh you're crazy sir nope
okay and remember don't pick that orbit
I don't I mean the incentive is terrible
they're basically telling you don't do
it because here get a grenade launcher
anyways back to this nope not back to
this loading alright yeah anyway oh
sorry about that I was hoping we'd be
able to see you babe why do it seems
really strange that the new machine in
this isn't on the map like I can't find
it
I gotta explore man but usually just
look at the map and it tells what if the
is a tower with a tower like help you
locate any of that stuff I mean the tall
neck should have done that that's always
trying to get the tall neck because I
figured it would show me where cuz I
mean like look anything else you wanna
find like Glen talk you go there
strange strange has Jake ever heard of
rope cast wait we're not doing another
child are we there's two more so you're
gonna try hoping that they're in the
other one I mean I think you have a
better chance looking around I think so
yeah I don't think so but okay you don't
think so then I'll go with your word on
why don't we try Chieftains trial okay
dangerous the most great not all
chieftains Fassett why can't you do it
is probably because you haven't done the
other one
Peter where can I find said add I'm
gonna literally walk hold on I'm gonna
ask you yeah that's a good idea
because Peter is being it so let me ask
the Peter Brown PD Brown here
while a jig does this trial here
see how good Peter is about responding
here oh god you're getting mauled it's a
hot rope caster action oh Jesus that's
like the same feeling I had when a dying
light and the color this guy's called
the really big dudes at Concha at night
but you could view that like reverse
shot and it was like so freaky get
hacked it wants to kill these things
with this but this thing is not very
good well you have it modded it right
get those hot mods baby mod mid-fight
bottom right yeah we got do to it
highest one yeah damn we ballin now I
hope it's like the most damaged
now now it definitely didn't cover the
damage
my tear arrows either
as an Turk would tell you you got to put
down some oh man there's more [ __ ]
coming with me I'm just gonna stay out
of it I will get a response from Peter
hopefully and not worst cases I'll open
the door and yell item in the office I
can also message someone out there
together
[Music]
you have to finish him with the storm
slinger thing so yeah I'm gonna weaken
them yeah feels good
what does the deeps do that guy's a weak
to it or something
yeah he's he's not liking it yeah just
in time
Oh should have been using that to start
that thing did so much work I think it's
just on normal difficulty right uh yeah
Jake you're doing work
three more with this and then what we're
done that's it
alright hope his noggin
yeah yeah I'm all about this shotgun
sudden shock good little crit
well crit I shot I shot oh that one
because it's a week
yeah nailed it okay no problem
so now you could technically do the
trial right the cheating trial I believe
so hell I got I got to full health Ben
djenka I don't know if you're watching
this stream but we did add electric
percentage ready was like 44 percent you
put his highest mod on it if you're out
there Ben I need Peter oh I still can't
even do it cool attention I'll hit up
this guy's pretty pretty responsible
we will find these new things I will I
promise you that in the meantime I want
you to get some herbs was that for sure
it's one of the new ones but it's not
like I modified I think it's one of the
new ones me look yeah it's one of the
new ones all right but not the bear yeah
doesn't show up yeah there's bro I
wouldn't say there's a tomb in chat
delay there's delay though for sure
alright I got someone on the case
trying to get Peters attention so you
can tell us what to do I think you
should herb up while I find out where to
go oh what's that
dad that might be one frost claw
yeah without a bear alright forget it
forget again we got it alright I need to
prepare look you seem knocking down
trees damn there's so much [ __ ] over
there alright I think you're gonna need
more than what you got oh yeah oh yeah
alright we found the bear guys
actually what I should do to look up
where he's weak oh man body is fire
shock and tear alright I your guns gonna
be great right it is but I need my tear
arrows too
okay make sure that's which bear is best
oh he just ran to the left like hella
far bear BBQ party I hope so
let's go okay Oh God
just kidding we might be fighting him
now all right no health or no extra
health except for your potions yeah he
is pissed he's hella big Oh Annie's got
so many buddies
that's her not to make me scared I'm
scared
Oh
that did like nothing
cool he doesn't know how to go in the
water
oh we're gonna use these hot water
tactics the bear doesn't like the water
you owe me hi is any warning or is that
the scorcher
that's the scorcher oh no the other knew
all right well you have to remember is
where this is on the map
not good well two-for-one nice this is
this is okay this is how this is how
we're gonna add the stream take some
kill both of these with like no health
because he's Jake wrecker
nice j-jake death er
this isn't even the bear looking Ferb's
kept casual looking for herbs
oh man alright now we're gonna get back
to the bear that that was prepared that
was an unfortunate rope cast enteric is
raging he wanted lack of rope casting
I've used that plenty of times I know he
just wants you to rope cast everything I
think he must love the rope cast here we
go oh [ __ ]
do you remember roughly where it was
kind of that's why I was gonna have you
to like pull up on there so they could
remember I think they're just north
right
I'm gonna hope you know where to go nice
one shake he's technically like that
like three times there's an you just go
true yes cowboy Johnny it's not very
fast it's like easy there's some quality
of life stuff in it alright where is mr.
bear then let's find the frost claw well
go
what I could try doing never falters er
in the stream
[Applause]
come on feel like you did the message by
the river I know that you did the map at
some point here Oh get it it's like a
frame no it's like five second frames
here that's the scorcher oh okay here it
was like roughly how is that true
roughly there okay that that like
roughly where you are now because the
objective was the same I just might have
been north of that though
come on give me another map get good
scrub thanks Jim I'm not playing though
ha ha
there's a bear okay there's a bear do
you show me the map show me the map Jake
this pass Jake pass Jake needs to help
out right now we're trying to find the
bear guys I'm watching the stream from
just now we'll just try to get a handle
of the map location so that we could try
potentially getting back there and
literally hoping Jake opens the map at
some point I thought you did for a hot
second
I really did all right where's that it's
wherever this is played a little bit
because the map hasn't loaded in yeah
that's what happens and I know how hard
it is for me to get back to that yeah
you don't do it up there where is that
its way north yeah you're its way north
of where you're at that's why I said the
first time it was North man we did
there's one thing I have it's a decent
memory the review is of the faux PJ
caught Peter Brown and reviewed it
you can check that out on the site as
well as YouTube can't find a bear blame
tape hey I'm not the one on the sticks
man III told them to like at some point
when he was fighting was like I think
he's gonna die he should probably just
like open the map so that he did
remember it's okay you're fighting so
it's tough it was somewhere up on the
path from the village thank you as well
as he banned we're on our way I just
gotta get we're fighting a loading boss
right now
all right we're going north like nah to
the right of that it's like even for it
yeah so it's like even farther I'll just
head that way I'm sure or actually no
you had it right the first time I was in
the mountains hard to miss yeah all
right feeling good about it we're gonna
fight the bear and I guess you got to
kind of make sure you don't go far too
far left of the bear because that
Scorchers there how are people playing
this already we have a review copy
Ashley Mingo and that embargo has come
up since the review embargo has come up
so so our show showing the game off also
chatting you all about some of your
questions and yeah alright so did I
fight the scorcher first no I think you
should just fight a bit go right for the
bay and then maybe just make sure you
don't go like oh I guess make sure you
have your bearings down so you know I
gotta somewhere you don't want to be
alright
let's see if we can find the bear
unless he doesn't spawn in the same area
which I know you're not usually how do
you get to work
oh yeah which bears best Jake oh here
goes actually I'm gonna find Mars
my health potions ready it's good tactic
you don't fear Ashley yeah you'll get it
in roughly a wysz hours but for now you
can watch us fight a bear and hopefully
kill it I have faith in Jake though put
the ones in chat if you think that
Jake's gonna kill the bear put the twos
if you think he's gonna die I think you
got to find a way to kill his buddies I
agree all right here comes the one in
the twos the ones in the twos are coming
through someone for the three obviously
uh there's a lot of two's right now who
is one I'm gonna die no one is you're
gonna kill it Susan you're gonna die we
just saw it barely Great Pond rowboat
ethics this little beaver whatever you
are he's not gonna be happy
what's up KC Carlyle are you one but
eventually he is going to to
she's already getting hit by his buddies
but the good news is hopefully you kill
these guys before he comes back up now
he's he's kind of on his way back all
right you're real close to filling this
guy all right just you and the bear you
own frost cloth do you remember his
weaknesses and whatnot oh look at this
hacker hi guys I have time to go look at
the weaknesses what are you doing I'm I
gotta get Tara I got teri we do so
terrorist all right use your terror and
just because what's-his-face Oh God
really wants me to use rope caster oh
yeah look at that look at this scratch
my god he's trying to give you a bear
hug you are on him
how come I don't know do this look at
this hot strategic stabbing him in the
butt buddy I see look how much damage
that did it was more that you're
supposed to use that for other means I
think I don't know I did the road caster
stuff out of ammo
removing its components do it get him
naked fire burn up he's got he's got
icicles he could throw at you yeah this
is a dangerous bear Jake does not have
the Weaver armor no yep bear hug I like
it we need to find a way out of this
foliage
unless you think that's the way to be oh
okay I'm gonna get this again all I have
to scan them yet there we go jeez I'm
nervous okay
no I can tell there's a big bear after
you we're analyzing him right now I want
to figure out it looks like there's no
way to disable his his ice powers yeah
that's what you don't like the fire
maybe he doesn't care about the fire
actually is it the heat it's healing him
bro no no that okay okay
I think Kareem I think he'll
all right he's weak against fire Jake
you know that now
good dodging there's more rope caster
yeah rope cast it I don't get rope
casted all right now we'll hit his weak
spots
oh he just knock you back wrap oh there
you go there you go go to sleep go to
sleep right in his thigh or whatever the
hell oh yeah look at all these damage Oh
watch out all right we're doing good
half half life here
[Applause]
yeah right into the weak spot under his
armpit I see it this guy's got range and
melee oh he's got hadoukens
Oh what was that oh I froze him up too
cuz he's uh yeah yeah yeah all right so
we figured something out here yep
oh man damn jams Jake is spamming
everything right now all for the stream
also he can show to you guys that you
should have put ones in the chat instead
of all those twos that you guys have
been so negative about dude he's
seriously dude how many shots does it
take that's like eight oh he's
[Applause]
oh wow that freezer
with this dress woman I'm not even
playing come on bear don't let me down
Wow
come on chat you're supposed to be on
our side oh yeah
Oh suck it oh good you got it yeah yeah
there you go
ah Jake showed you guys you still had a
whole like thing the hell - yeah I'm
good yeah no problem
how would you get you got anything good
all right the satisfaction of victory
though I didn't get that - that's - I
think I think we reached the pinnacle of
our live stream I don't think we can top
lay down
yeah that was pretty cool so that was
horizon zero dawn the frozen wilds DLC
that's out yeah and about eight and
eight and a little change of hours from
now Thank You Jake for playing and
slaying a bear oh you're gonna get next
to it in photo mode oh yeah she's got
poses now right yeah I'm hot Zelda
breath of the wild type stuff okay next
well Jake so yeah thanks again Jake for
playing any quick final thoughts as as
you selfie this bear I mean I think if
you want more horizon zero dawn this is
gonna be perfect for you it's not I mean
the story seems okay but like just
playing it's so much fun like the
gameplay is great should we do does he
does she have one of the like the Zelda
ones where yeah oh wow hearts put your
hearts out in chat a little Neil a
little hope aftermath what is what is
going on stargazing steadfast oh man
there's so many there's so many uh all
right I guess Jake is going with that
reflecting on his bear kill see so she
does have the hand thing anyways yeah so
if you're if you want more horizon zero
dawn obviously is a good good time to go
I think it's $15 if you pre-order today
after that $19.99
so the complete edition comes out in
December thank you all for tuning in
again Sam Smith the map we showed that
earlier you can just DVR back leave it
on there and so check it out that way if
you haven't subscribed to hit follow and
liked all that stuff you should do that
so you guys get notified when we go live
with cool streams like this we do it
every day at 11:00 a.m. tomorrow we'll
be doing destiny I'll be here for the
weekly reset Wednesday the lobby
and then Thursday Fridays kind of up in
the air why some do once which may be
spitting need for sweet payback maybe
Neil completed addition at some point
that comes out tomorrow but until then
thank you guys thank you Jake thank you
for all the people who had faith in me
that's right all the ones in chat see
you guys
you